tell me first about your observations on
what's going on in Syria right now do
you think the military action is
justified well you know I think what
we've seen in Syria is another use of
chemical weapons by the Syrian regime
anything as much doubt about that and
it's too late to affect the outcome of
the Syrian civil war but it is important
that the Western world reestablishes the
taboo against using chemical weapons
that was established after the First
World War and the ghastliness is in the
in the trenches 1925 Geneva Protocol
outlawed it it was then a chemical
weapons convention which basically
required the dismantling of all chemical
weapons stocks back in 1997 so I think
it is important that sort of taboo
against chemical weapons it's got a bit
frayed in recent years and we need to
reestablish it and I think this is
important that there is a reaction to it
I think this is a common Western
approach I think when we deal with
breaches of international norms it's
right there should be Western solidarity
we saw that in the wake of the attack on
on scrip al in Salisbury where we had
very widespread international concern
solidarity with the British measures and
I think there needs to be solidarity
amongst Western countries and how we
deal with the chemical weapons use I'm a
security adviser I'm not a
parliamentarian but I think actually
David Cameron made a mistake back in
2013 referring this department
Parliament is there to debate and decide
on legislation and to hold the
government to account it's not there to
take executive decisions of government
this is an executive decision of
government and rests with the prime
minister in the cabinet do you think
people like glad Amir Putin President
Assad the kind of people that have to
to respond is that the only way of
getting them to talk or change their
behavior well III think with the likes
of Mossad yes that is that probably is
the only way to get Assad to change his
behaviors he has to pay a price for his
use of chemical weapons I think with the
Russians it's more complex than that I
think the Russians we have to be very
clear about what our intentions are what
is unacceptable in terms of Russian
behavior and to have the investment in
our own defence both both military
defense and security defense cyber
defense to to deal with Russian threats
to us and hostile actions by Russia but
we also need very clear lines of
communication with the Russians to
reduce and remove the the chances of
misunderstandings and we had that during
the Cold War it slipped frankly over the
last decade or so and we need to
re-establish that we're not going to
agree with the Russians but they do need
to know very clearly what it is that we
stand for and what we're going to do so
that that risk of miscalculation is
removed
why have those diplomatic channels I
think it goes back to the the period
really after the war in Georgia in 2008
and when Putin moved from being
president - Prime Minister and we rather
lost that reality that actually Putin
was still the most important man in
Russia is still the decision taker and I
don't think President Obama did us any
favors by treating Putin with a degree
of disrespect and almost contempt it was
someone like President Putin you need to
build him up and deal with him as an
equal rather than to push him down so I
think this is a problem which is going
been going back almost 10 years now and
we have to rebuild a capacity - to talk
directly to put in unto his people
and to manage between us the very
serious differences of opinion that we
have with Russia but how do we in the UK
do that wake of the script poisoning
well I think actually Theresa Mays done
pretty well so far in managing the the
fallout from that and it's about showing
a leave should be very firm in response
to the Russians and working closely with
our natural partners in in Europe in
America in NATO and across the world how
much damage do you think has been done
to the protocols of the way the
intelligence world worked in the way
that scrip I was apparently singled out
an attack well we we don't know the
exact details and what happened inside
the Russia system clearly he was
convicted and Russia back in 2004 I
think it was he was exchanged in 2010
during my time as chief of mi6 after
being pardoned by the Russian system he
wasn't hiding at all in the UK he stayed
in contact with his family in Russia so
it was I think it's the first time any
of us can recall that a someone involved
in that sort of spy swap was
subsequently targeted in a in a an
attempt to kill them so yes that that
changes some of the rules equally the
use of chemical weapons is an even
bigger change to the rules of the game
use of chemical weapons in a civilian
environment in a in a NATO country there
needs to be a very clear response to
that a proportional response of course
now you make your money these days you
make a living these days from advising
businesses on global trends global
geopolitical trends macroeconomic trends
the trade war the risk of one is clearly
at the center of that
now how do you see relations between the
US and China panning out well I think
this is a serious challenge President
Trump I think is right to call out there
the Chinese for some of their trade
practices especially the theft of
intellectual property and it's it's
Trump style we've come to understand
this now he kicks up a lot of dust a bit
of a furore and trying to put the other
side on the back foot and then starts
negotiating with them hard to do that
with China but he's he's made a start
all these threats of fifty billion
dollars worth of goods subjects in new
tariffs and Italian by America maybe
never have a China maybe another hundred
billion dollars of of goods in involve
nothing's actually happened yet none of
these tariffs have yet been introduced
so there is a period for negotiation and
for karma heads to to prevail but there
is a problem that this trade competition
between United States and China is
happening at the same time as strategic
challenges over North Korea and to some
extent of Taiwan as well this
administration has injected Taiwan into
the into the agenda and that's an issue
on which President Xi Jinping has got no
flexibility at all so it's quite a
complex situation which is boiling up
there and will have impact for all four
major Western companies operating in
China not just joining presumably South
Korea Japan of course across the region
yeah incumbents using pink now to
respond I think the the Chinese are
willing to engage in a negotiation with
the Americans on this and I think the
speech that President Xi gave the other
day indicated a bit of flexibility in
here the Chinese think that they can
believe that they can deal with
President Trump by giving a little bit
of ground because the long-term trends
of all in their favor
and I think President Trump is also
looking for a deal there are of course
some ideologues in the US administration
and probably some in the Chinese system
as well who would like a more
confrontational approach I think Trump
and she will both look for a deal it's
question of whether they can as two big
egos two big powerful leaders they can
find space for both of them in the same
room Trump does seem to like doing I
think that's right and we're seeing it
on another trade issue on NAFTA he's
again kicking up a lot of dust softening
up the parties in Mexico in Canada I
think he's looking for a deal something
quite like you I don't I think he's a
singularly ill-prepared and unsuited
person to be present United States the
fact is he was elected by the American
people gonna have to deal with him and
in this situation you know some of his
instincts aren't misplaced he's right
about China trade practices he's right
that the use of chemical weapons is
completely unacceptable the rather
intellectualized approach that President
Obama took has been led to the wrong
answers frankly so he's not my choice of
President of the United States he's not
someone I welcome but he is gonna be
President probably for the next two and
a half years maybe for the next six and
a half years we're gonna get used to it
now one of the other big geopolitical
macro themes right now is of course the
advance of Technology automation
should ordinary members of the public be
about their job security there's no
doubt that artificial intelligence and
the use of data analytics is going to
put more emphasis on technology and less
on on people not only unskilled people
but but skilled people as well like
lawyers and accountants and doctors
although their work in the future is
going to be done by by machines and more
effectively than people can do them at
the end of the day it's going to be a
combination of people and machines which
will produce the most that the best the
optimum outcomes for for corporates
corporations the the issue is how to
invest in and use new technology as it
comes on stream and also it's important
if not more so how do you attract and
retain the talented people needed to
master and and use this this new
technology I think the pitiful dimension
is an understated part of the technology
challenge and we know the technology is
coming we know technological change is
is if Eve anything still accelerating
its getting the talented people from all
across the world into the right
positions where they can where they can
really show their talents inside of
inside a major companies there's
obviously a growing awareness of data
privacy Zuckerberg of Facebook oh I I
didn't watch every hour of his his
testimony but I think he came under a
good deal of pressure he spent a lot of
time in recent months apologizing for
Facebook's poor practices in the past I
think we all are getting to a stage
where the control of data is shifting
more to the consumer we're seeing the
GDP are the general the general data
protection regulation coming into force
this month I think it is and that
highlights that in Europe data is going
to be the responsibility of the consumer
the individual in America is still the
responsibility of the corporate in
China's responsible
the state under the control of the state
I think the European approach is
probably the best and the way in which
the gdpr has global reach I think will
have an impact on other jurisdictions
especially Democratic Western leaning
ones so I think this is an era where the
EU is ahead of the game and they're
setting global standards so do you think
in time the US might introduce gdpr
regulation well I think at the moment
the tech companies have a very dominant
position and actually under this
administration in particular there's not
much will to change that because the
tech companies are too important of
American political parties but over time
the American tech companies are going to
have to adjust to gdpr and it will have
an having an impact in America as well
because it's about the protection of the
data of European residents across the
entire world which means operating in
the US as well do you think in time
their financial returns will also have
to be regulated I mean Zuckerberg denied
that they're a monopoly the other day
but they'll do exhibit
utility like yeah well we have the CEOs
of two major banks on the stage here at
the Wall Street Journal conference just
before lunch and each of those banks
paid more in tax in the last 12 months
around the world than Facebook or Apple
or Amazon or Netflix have ever paid in
their entire existence and their comment
from the stage was that the global
taxation system has to change to to
reflect the new realities and again I
think the European Union's likely to be
in the lead on this this is something
that has to be done on the basis of
jurisdictional matter but someone's
gonna have to take the lead and it looks
as though it's gonna be Europe Europe of
course in which the UK is no longer
going to be part
for the euro so from now you be very
clear you think Breck's it's a mistake
in them assuming it happens how does the
UK position itself globally to remain
relevant and indeed competitive yeah I
do think it's a mistake I think we've
already seen that as a request a brexit
the Perim is devalued our growth rate
has gone from the strongest in the g7
countries to the weakest in the g7
countries that's just inside two years
but I do think we're going to have to
get accustomed to it I think we need to
minimize the damage of brexit as far as
we can but then also strengthen our
financial services industries our
technology industries so that the
despite brexit we can still grow and
prosper as a company as a country and I
think we've got some talents that will
enable us to do that I was talking to a
senior minister last night who was
saying that this was someone who
supported the remain side of the of the
equation but that one of the impacts of
of BRICS it will at least be that we've
dealt with the extreme right in British
politics that they will somehow be
neutered by this brexit process quite a
price to pay for doing that but we won't
have the current challenge of extreme
right factions impacting on British
politics we saw what a hard left faction
we have to deal with as well but if we
can get as a result of brexit if we can
get politics and Britain back to as a
consensus around the center around
national interests and build a strong
economy again then who knows in 5-10
years time we could be back on our feet
and and have respect around the world
you've spoken a lot of importance
decline really that the UK's had since
the end of the first world is it though
the Britain is a player on the world
stage I mean we're sort of middle
ranking nation army when we we still
have an important strength in the world
and we have a lot of respect around the
world as well and a lot of natural
advantages as a country it's a dangerous
and difficult world we can shy away from
those dangers we can sort of bury our
heads under the pillow and and just
focus on life inside Britain the reality
is if you don't confront a challenge
whether it's the cyber threat or whether
it's the use of grain use of chemical
weapons then that threat gets closer and
closer to you I'd much rather have a
world in which countries like Britain
shape the global environment than one in
which it's shaped by others like China
or Russia or Iran and we sort of tied
ourselves away for a generation or so
and leave it to our children or our
children's children to pick up the
pieces